a lot of new revelations unfold this
season one of them being in the first
episode obviously i come to this
this big conclusion that i need to be
honest with myself and honest with my
friends and those who love me that
that i am worried about the age
difference i think i reach this
breaking point or like point of self
revelation
where like i realize how much self work
i need to do
and i mean i do struggle with anxiety
and depression
season four of siesta key is basically
here how would each of you guys describe
this season as a whole this season was
a long one yes
i think there was a lot of growth a lot
of growth a lot of vulnerabilities
but i think in order to get to that
place i think we had to like hit rock
bottom
yeah i think they hung out at rock
bottom for a minute yeah i learned a lot
this season yeah like i'm glad
everything happened the way it did
because it's gotten me to where i am
right now and i've realized a lot
i want to talk to each of you about your
story lines but kelsey will start with
you
at the end of season three we saw things
turn pretty sour between
you and juliet over the rivalry
bikini lines mostly what is going on
with the friendship today
i think with like the end of last season
and like i've gone i met up with sam
like obviously uh
i totally regret like all of that and
i've apologized time and time again
since then like i don't think she was
able to forgive me
and throughout the season you kind of
see just like
a lot of animosity and just like goes
more and more downhill but
when it comes to the swimmer like that's
not anything
i'm concerned about i don't think it's a
competition i think we live in florida
there's
plenty of room for one two ten swimmer
lines
a hundred swimmer lines like i don't
care but completely fine
we have different visions and she's done
amazing like her
swimmer line looks amazing i'm really
proud of her from a business standpoint
and so
that's good but then there's just other
things that happen throughout the season
that you guys will see unravel
and so now we're to the point where
we're just doing our own things
kelsey i feel like your mindset about
the entire thing is actually very
healthy and mature
i think you have a new man named max yes
who is max can we get some details
max is awesome uh i definitely think
like going into this season i was super
nervous bringing him into this group
because
obviously like we're a lot and being on
a reality show yeah but
i think overall he did a good job i'm
proud of him but you guys will
see that transition and i'm just excited
for everyone to get to know him and
i'm could not be happier with him how
serious are things between you guys
um i would say
pretty serious i don't like give
anything away but um
are you engaged also no okay
all right um i think he's definitely
like taking a lot of sacrifices for me
this past year and throughout the season
that i appreciate
so i plan on doing the same for him in
the future and so we'll just see where
it goes
is it all smooth sailing for you guys or
are there
rocky roads during the season
um i mean absolutely like we're like any
relationship but i
think more so in this season you'll see
my like me struggle with
myself and then other friends and so i
think like
he's never he's never brought around the
script before and so he's only dealt
with like me and i'm not like drama when
it comes to like just him not
and so for him for the first time to
like see me involved in drama then he's
like
what is going on so i think that was
really hard for him to have to deal with
and like see me going through these
things and not really be able to like
do anything and like i had to go through
that for myself all right madison
lots of questions for you you've always
been very open about
your relationship with ish you are
engaged
now talk to me about wedding planning is
there a date set
do you have a dress what's going on well
i don't want to give away too much
but we're not married yet you won't see
a wedding this season
um and part of it is just it was really
overwhelming for me to plan a wedding
during a global pandemic
my parents are older his parents are
older we didn't really want
to put them in a situation where they're
around a ton of people
um but also you know i i had i came to
this realization you know that i have to
do a lot of self-discovery and i have to
you know face a lot of things before i
can get to that point i feel like i have
to put on this
front like oh i don't care about the age
i do a lot of
new revelations unfold this season one
of them being in the first episode
obviously i come to this
this big conclusion that i need to be
honest with myself and honest with my
friends and those who love me like that
i am worried about the age difference
and for so long i think
because i had like the world against me
like even my
close friends i found out were talking
smack about the age difference and i
thought you know i have no one i have no
support system
so i had to overcompensate and be like
oh the age difference doesn't matter at
all to me
and in fact like i do think about it and
it is something that
scares me but that doesn't mean you know
that we're not meant to be it just means
it's
it's one of our hurdles every
relationship has them and it's one of
the things you know we have to
face and so i finally i came to i faced
that
did it feel nice to sort of get those
feelings i guess
off of your chest and were you able to
share those concerns with ish
yes i have we have had these discussions
and it was
it was nice to finally be able to open
up about that
and finally say it out loud you know
because i don't think i even admitted it
to myself
and so yeah it was it was very
therapeutic you said it doesn't mean
that you're not each other's person do
you think you will walk down the aisle
i know i will walk down that aisle i
have there's no doubt in my mind
that we will have that big moment
whatever it looks like it might not be
what
what i had imagined when i was a kid of
my dream wedding it might be
looked a little different and that's
okay and i've i've changed my
kind of because of this year i've kind
of changed my idea of what
my future wedding will look like i got
goosebumps
absolutely there will be a wedding day
um we've also seen you
talk about your desire to be a mom a lot
on the show are you guys actively trying
right i know just a little bit
are you actively trying right now or do
you want to
have the wedding first i mean i guess i
don't want to say too much
um but
okay um but it's
it's an ongoing conversation for sure
and it's something that
will be in our future i don't know what
that looks like again but
we're going to figure that out and we
will have kids one day
i know a wedding can happen at any point
we're going to be together forever
and you know a family kind of seems like
the priority
so we'll see but
um nothing's nothing's in stone as of
now
i think had coped not happen we would be
married by now so i think there's like a
lot of elements to
coming to this conclusion and yeah
for each of you guys is there anything
that you are
nervous to have to relive as you watch
back
the island the island okay what happens
on
the island because brandon and also
shared some concerns about the island
i think everyone really struggled like
as a whole um
especially me i think in all four
seasons
i never hit more of like a hard point
i think than in this season while on
island
personally it gets pretty volatile yeah
it's
pretty intense what about what will be
the most emotional moment
for each of you guys this season
um for me i think i reached this
breaking point or like point of self
revelation
where like i realize how much self
work i need to do and i mean i i do
struggle with anxiety and depression and
i have my whole life and
i think this year especially hit really
hard
and so it was a big journey of mental
health for me
and that was hard to open up about on
camera so
yeah that's a big one i was gonna say i
don't feel like we've ever actually seen
you
talk about that before so why was now
the time and how are you doing now i
think i'm doing great thank you
um i'm going to therapy and all the
wonderful things that
i can do for myself and self-love um
but i think there was a point where i
was like i can no longer avoid this
i have to face this and i have it's
gonna be like dangerous
so that was tough but i
i did it and i'm really proud of myself
and like i'm nervous to watch it back
but i'm also excited to see myself like
get through that
and also like other people i know it's
so relatable and i know
so many people are like there's such a
stigma against it and it's like it's
very
hard for people to open up and talk
about it was there a moment
of self-realization where you felt like
i need to get
some help yeah i think there were a few
there were a few i'm very lucky to have
kelsey and ish and a good support system
on
like in my life and on the show um
who are there around me during filming
and during
not filming you know on and off camera
so
um yeah i feel very lucky to have a
support system because i don't know if i
could have done it without you guys but
i really don't
well make me cry like you said social
media is a big
big part of it and i talk about that a
lot on the show and just like
i especially like it's so hard you're
not meant to have 500 000
eyes on you and talking giving their
opinion and so it's very hard for me
i've always wanted to like please
everyone and yeah
come to the realization you can't do
that you people are like you set up this
it's like yeah i don't think anyone
signs up for that
you